Have you ever heard somebody say,
I can't watch black and white movies,
I have a problem with this,
not because some of the most important
movies are in black and white,
but because black and white can do just
as much,
if not more than color.
The best place to prove this point is
film noir,
a style of filmmaking that continues to
influence modern cinematography
everywhere,
including breaking bad,
but I'm getting ahead of myself.
I want to focus on film the war as a
style to make the case for black and
white film making.
The first question is,
what is film noir?
I actually don't think it requires a
concrete definition because it's
something you can feel,
especially in modern parodies by saying,
I see what this is going.
Chicago know the conversation that
predictable.
Only one.
I can tell what you're going to do next.
Maybe my favorite parody of the style is
Calvin and Hobbes.
Comic Strip can perfectly embodied the
cinematography of film noir,
the contrast of light and black,
the white trail of cigarette smoke,
the long shadows,
and the dramatic morally ambiguous
narrative,
but let's unpack that to start.
Let's consider black and white on Rob
Snl parodied Casa Blanca recently and
shot in black and white,
rigid.
They are parenting this.
See notice a difference in the look of
each shot in the snl sketch.
The contrast is extremely low.
If I take a sample of the darkest shade
in the shot and compare it to the
lightest shade in the shot,
you see there isn't much difference
between the two.
Compare that difference to the
difference in Casa Blanca.
The darkest shade on screen is nearly
black,
while the brightest shade on screen is
nearly white.
This dynamic range of shading makes for
a more interesting shot composition and
it really showcases how black and white
can make such an interesting look with
higher contrast.
I know I'm comparing Casa Blanca to a
sketch comedy TV show,
but it does show how black and white Kim
look boring and I think a lot of people
see black and white this way.
Let's see the beauty of black and white
in an experiment.
Let's take a stock photo in color of a
stage picture that's got the film noir
style.
Let's try de Saturating it.
Upping the contrast and adding some
shadow.
Now look at it.
The background is it distracting from
the subject.
The shadows from the blinds are more
pronounced,
more focus is placed on her facial
features like lips and eyebrows.
The simplicity of black and white means
that the I can observe more key features
in the shock colors,
great,
but sometimes simple is better in the
age of color.
Filmmakers going for that noir feel.
Have two options.
The first is mimic in our budding color.
Blast the screen with bright,
vibrant colors to give the same level of
contrast and aesthetic as black and
white movies,
or do the opposite film in color,
but make the coloring so monochromatic
that it almost looks black and white.
You can see this in many gritty movies
like seven inbound,
black and white filming emphasizes
contrast,
so it can be used for visual
storytelling.
The classic blind shot shows a character
that is literally dark and light.
Lighting is filmed in extremes.
One side of the character is brightly
lit.
The other side is completely black.
They've got a good side and a dark side.
You may not actively acknowledged these
details,
but they subtly remind the viewer
through lighting that the character
might have a dark side,
or at least it makes the scene much more
threatening.
Black and white film making gave cinema
these techniques.
We still see them in color and they work
well,
but black and white has a much stronger
look because of the contrast.
This sequence in breaking bad screams
film noir.
If I make this black and white,
you could even confuse it as an old
flick.
I'm not saying breaking bad should have
been filmed in black and white,
but what I am saying is that breaking
bad's gorgeous cinematography owes
itself to the techniques that shine the
strongest in black and white movies.
Actually breaking bad has filmed noir
lighting everywhere.
The blinds,
the good side,
and the dark side,
high contrast and smoking smoke looks
gorgeous in a black and white movie.
The movie,
the Big Combo shows all the beauty of
black and white in this shot.
Silhouettes,
smoke high contrast.
It looks fantastic.
So if you want to convince somebody that
black and white has merrick,
give them a movie that shows off what
high contrast and low key lighting can
do.
Show them a film noir,
strong lights,
strong blacks,
strong picture.
So Scott,
the thing or the blacks are like,
really?
Really,
really
thanks for watching.
Slightly full.
Just a bit of a break from the norm.
Just to break the monotony of all that.